oggi ci prepariamo a qualcosa di intenso
non so se ve l'ho mai detto ma io sono
un grande fan della saga di residenti vi
stanno facendo il re master ed del 2
l'ho scaricato su play 4 lo stop a
giocare adesso è una demo che è uscita
dura solo 30 minuti vuol dire che noi
abbiamo 30 minuti per poterci giocare
poi la demo finisce non puoi più
giocarci prevedere che cosa esce fuori
non lo so non ho idea non l'ho mai
giocata è uscita oggi
oggi quando lo sto registrando voi lo
state vedendo mi pare domenica quindi
riuscita a l'altro ieri mi sto già
cagando sotto però vabbè 30 minuti di
gioco non di più a ha così ok va bene ma
cosa vuol dire che sta sta già sta già
correndo il tempo va bene non c'è
nessuno che doppiato ma che figata
matilda matilda è la pistola bellissima
stanza miliare mattina non la esaminiamo
che ci abbiamo poco tempo vai apri di
quanto è figo lione ragazzi da 1 milione
ai miei vecchi capelli c'è una
combinazione ragazzi che ovviamente non
so quindi non ne ho idea
a meno che non la faccia che c'è una
combinazione che ovviamente so è che
l'ho fatto perché ho scoperto le cose
giuste
bene andiamo avanti bene così sappiate
che io vado avanti nei giochi grazie a
queste cose se non grazie alla mia
intelligenza se no saremmo in alto mare
si apre qualcosa in questa stanza
comunque che ho trovato una di tre
simboli che dovevo mettere in giro mi
sembra già una bomba per come ci sto
giocando cioè per quel poco che vi posso
dire
per il resto vedremo mi piaceva
camminata tra l'altro forse quel simbolo
riera il più difficile da prendere gli
altri sono molto più semplici
solo che non ho idea di dove si trovino
c'è qualcosa proietti macchina da
scrivere che perciò la partita questo
veloce però che c'è tempo che scorre a
ma lui dai sono io family friendly non
lo sai tu
cioè quello ci avevano uno zombie che li
sta saltando in faccia e nel mentre
parla alla videocamera facetime loggando
k corrie
ma ti pare cerco io ci penso io a questo
poi dove inserisci gli oggetti che trovi
bene il gioco a uno zombie e lo piglio
in tutto il gioco a meno keep out tra
laddove c strisci sistri sci non
promette benissimo ma non fa niente
a farci persone gems che sono poco
abituato queste a questi non colpi di
scena sembra veramente figo
cosa è successo
sento rumori messo ci sono delle casse
potrebbero essere di buona qualità
se lui le ha ascoltate non sono di buona
qualità
io sento rumori ovunque non so quale sia
il problema
sento rumori o discorso del presidente
stati uniti siete fatti bene vediamo se
funziona la mia idea non ha funzionato o
stai calma calma calma di arrivo non
dire parolacce ma ci penso io
dammi d'amico la cosa che in mano grazie
nel mentre che ti mangiano le gambe sono
zombie l'agio aiuto erano
me l'aspettavo me lo aspettavo ecco
questo mi sa che non è che mi riprende
però vabbè lasciamo lì lo zio che è
successo pure ragazzi il primo colpo che
ho sforato i residenti vol non era dei
migliori
il secondo che è ancora ancora a poi è
morto bene non è morto scherzavo via aia
vi si è pagato nella porta e se paga
fincas viene incastrato in mezzo
e vabbé via via via di qua veloci veloci
veloci e vabbè madonna piazza che ciò
no ragazzi puoi buttarla e niente mi
sono fatto malissimo
corri corri laiche there is no tomorrow
e lei le uscite di là nomi ricorrono
ancora l'uscita
dunque quando gli zombie tickle ti
colpiscono non dovresti tipo
trasformarti questa roba non hai capito
di aria via via via striscia veloce e
c'è gente
no no no
grazie un videogioco per le famiglie
grazie fratello chiusa il lazzaro sono
stato morso anche tu non stai messo con
un po di budella di fuori
la porterò all'ospedale
no io non sono una priorità ma io non la
lascerò questo è un ordine recluta sì
però spiega pensare a salvarti allora io
c'ho un simbolo solo ok mancano tutti
gli altri posso passare di qua c'è una
porta aperta in sto posto una allora
usato cosa mi sono recuperato la vita
perché sono stato messo malissimo di là
non ci vado più
quindi deduco che gli altri persino da
queste parti cola tipo qua a col
coltello posso tagliare lo scotch
giustamente un'altra zona
ci vediamo all'inferno amico mio bene
sono contento che l'ambientazione se non
tutte così della serie non c'è un
momento tranquillo non farlo proprio
vabbè
è un chewing gum sto tizio salve è a
posto lei basta che stia fermo
continuiamo ragazzi dal traguardo
mancano 16 minuti siamo già a metà ma
come come è possibile che siamo già a
metà tempo
corri fa qualcosa non ce la farò mai
risolvere l'enigma in tempo cioè quello
dei dischi cavolo messo video mette
bilico che martin carico ma che poi è
bello che ci vogliono 800 colpi per
farli fuori dio mio
ancora e basta la foto qua bene tessera
weapon l'occhio key card a questo penso
che sia per prendere le armi da un
ripostiglio di armi solo che non so dove
stiamo andando mi servono dei dischi
lancio tempo di legge il rapporto è il
già poco tempo come si fanno a forse col
coltello no non posso sparargli e bassa
sti cosi va beh
la catena la lasciamo là
ma cosa c'entra la di polizia effetto
gli armadietti sono qua quindi devo
raggiungere gli amaretti non so come ho
molto bene l'udc e fred vai lyon fai
vedere che se un figo cosa sta cercare
ndene e cioè tre yacht per farlo fuori
incredibile però è bellissimo quando gli
spari perché fanno esattamente quello
che dovrebbero fare morire allora
armadietti armadietti la c'è gente che
possiamo andarci a iniqua che non mi
piace tanto metti metti 20 mt
non è vero ho trovato roba forte rega
fermi tutti fratello test test sulla
testa di qua non so dove sto andando
regalo dunque non sono andato buongiorno
stai pure fuori poi dietro di qualcosa
felice come una porta le erba questa
sera per sembra una cosa brutta ma in
reatà sempre cuperare vita ha poi poi
sono le piante che puoi combinare
insieme in teoria giusto aspettavate
si si lo so miscela di piante questi
staff ai gunners più misceli le piante
in base a questa cosa ti curi di più
cioè questa è una cosa che è sempre
stata così precedenti
andiamo avanti e una sola zona e ci sono
un miliardo di cos'era fa guarda quanta
roba
la donna ma incredibile devi reggerti
tutti i documenti tutte europee così per
capire come si aprono le robe come ci
arrivo lì uno non un tempo 2 dove so
dove sono hai idea di contributi
buongiorno sono di passaggio tranquilli
scherzavo ma quanti e robe ma vi rendete
conto che in 30 minuti impossibile fare
tutte ste robe c'è uno dovrebbe aprire
tutti gli armadietti ma sei pazzo
ogni stanza ci sono cinque i nigmi o
solo sette minuti altro po come faccio a
fare sta roba spiega mi ci sono sono
tornato qui ci ho messo una vita e mezza
ha dotato ma spero che non gli zombie
non apra una porta in teoria no dimmi ho
scoperto questo youtube
siamo sui gay vieni guarda qua lo sapevo
ma chi la conosce anzi si chiama clero
sono arrivato come puoi raggiungere il
cortile dal piano di sopra
no no come hanno completato in 17 minuti
ma no dai
ma no va bene non va bene così volevo
fare fare robe accedere alla pagina però
vista del gioco è volevi se avessi fatto
quei cinque minuti in più la verità
ragazzi questa resident evil peccato
perché l'ho giocato di meno di quanto
dovevo giocarlo di più mancavano quei
cinque minuti ma mai e la morte vabbè
dai ragazzi miei spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto e mi sono divertito un
sacco
se volete la serie quando esce il gioco
poi il rapporto fatemi sapere quasi ai
ragazzi viene facilmente mi piace anche
voi siete quindi devono iniziare se non
sai come si schieri e noi come sempre
ragazzi ci vediamo a un prossimo video
perso il telecomando perso tutto la
dignità gli enigmi tutto per però va bè
ragazzi
[Musica]